[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo a América por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañera más Romero
Omar Buenos días Buenos días Andrés mar
vamos a empezar hablando de alzheimer
hay nuevos hallazgos en la relación que
une la genética y está demencia sí es
una historia que a mí particularmente me
ha causado muchísima curiosidad sobre
todo porque Además
está encerrada en un pueblito no muy
lejos de aquí no sé si conoces el pueblo
de yarumal que está a tres horas al
norte de Medellín aproximadamente un
pueblo de la región Paisa antioqueña
colombiana que pues en este pueblo
desgraciadamente sufren de una mutación
genética heredada probablemente desde el
siglo XVIII de una persona española un
hombre una mujer que viajó hasta allí
les heredó esta mutación que hace que
tengan y que desarrollen una demencia
precoz Alzheimer precoz hay unos 6.000
descendientes de esta persona en estas
familias hay unas 1200 con esta mutación
de hecho durante décadas se pensó que
era una maldición o algo el resultado de
brujería hasta que se dio ahora en
cuenta no de que en verdad es culpa de
esta mutación y también el resultado de
décadas y décadas de aislamiento y de
Pues relacionamiento dentro de ellos
mismos no dentro de las mismas
comunidades los científicos de la
Universidad de Antioquia llevan años
investigando esta población para
intentar desvelar las claves de una
enfermedad tan Misteriosa como el
alzheimer que afecta a tantos millones
de personas y han descubierto varias
cosas en la más reciente hallazgo se
publicó precisamente ayer en la revista
el primero por supuesto está cuando
identificaron no la mutación que está
detrás de esta demencia precoz y que
lleva el nombre de mutación Paisa de
hecho por el gentilicio pues Popular de
esta región antioqueña de Colombia pero
luego también encontraron dos personas
que eran resistentes a pesar de tener
esta mutación que les daría desarrollar
demencia precoz lograron resistir el
alzheimer durante décadas la primera fue
una mujer que se llamaba aliria y le
descubrieron esta mutación llamada
Christ Church y luego este reciente
hallazgo del que vamos a hablar hoy el
que nos vamos a focalizar hoy es un
segundo caso una mutación distinta
llamada colbos por Colombia y Boston así
la bautizaron que fueron los dos lugares
donde se desarrolló la investigación el
segundo caso por lo tanto de un hombre
resistente genéticamente a este
Alzheimer al que habría estado condenado
Si no tuviera una mutación genética
específica en este caso protectora que
contrarresta los efectos de la mutación
dañina es decir una mutación que protege
contra el alzheimer que sabemos de esta
mutación de esta segunda mutación pues
primero este paciente no tenemos su
nombre se llama paciente j y es el
principal sujeto del estudio pero se
sabe que su hermana también tenía esa
misma mutación las personas que tienen
la mutación países es decir la mutación
dañina que les provoca el alzheimer
precoz empiezan con el deterioro
cognitivo leve a los 44 años muy
temprano Es verdaderamente dramático y
empiezan con la demencia ya severa a
partir de los 49 años como vemos muy
pronto para este tipo de enfermedades
sin embargo el paciente J no mostró
deterioro cognitivo hasta los 67 años es
decir 20 años después de lo que se
esperaría que hubiera empezado a
desarrollar síntomas del Alzheimer y a
los 72 años demencia y su hermana de la
que se tiene mucha menos información
pero también se recogen algunos datos
sabemos que empezó con el deterioro
cognitivo a los 58 años y a los 61 años
con demencia entonces también había un
retraso de más de una década Respecto a
los cuadros clínicos que se esperan de
las personas que tienen esta mutación
Paisa y que aún así es una edad muy
temprana para para que comiences muy
temprana Pero al menos son 10 20 años
después mar la mutación protege partes
específicas del cerebro relacionadas con
esta demencia sí sabemos lo hemos
explicado varias veces que el alzheimer
está muy relacionado una de sus señas
pues claramente distinguibles es que se
acumulan proteínas en el cerebro y la
acumulación de beta amiloide en el
cerebro que impide que las neuronas
transmitan bien información y luego los
llamados ovillos como unos enredos de la
proteína dentro de las neuronas qué
hicieron compararon los cerebros de las
de las personas con la mutación dañina y
por lo tanto Alzheimer temprano y el
cerebro del paciente j y vieron por
ejemplo estas zonas que están en rojo en
este gráfico son las zonas donde el
paciente tenía muchas menos proteínas
tau que los sus compañeros que sí habían
desarrollado Alzheimer precoz algunas de
estas zonas están en el lóbulo temporal
medio que es precisamente la zona del
cerebro relacionada con el procesamiento
de la memoria y con también la
percepción del tiempo dos de las cosas
que se ven más afectadas Precisamente en
los pacientes que desarrollan demencia
no mientras que en cambio Es verdad que
hay zonas que están Igualmente dañadas
Pero al menos tenemos este mapa de estos
lugares específicos algo que es
interesante también Es que esto es
relativo precisamente a la proteína tau
pero que en caso de la proteína Beta
amiloide que sabemos que también está
relacionado con el alzheimer estaba
Igualmente dañado se sabía que lo había
acumulado durante años sin embargo
mostrar síntomas de ahora la gran
pregunta alrededor de todo esto es qué
hallazgo representan estos para el
futuro Sí por supuesto Siempre que
hablamos de estos descubrimientos
tenemos que pensar que nos puede
comportar en el futuro y especialmente
en una investigación como la enfermedad
del Alzheimer no por ejemplo pues
tenemos ahora cosas que antes no
teníamos mapas del cerebro de dos
personas que resistieron hasta Alzheimer
hereditario durante décadas sabemos que
en el primer caso por ejemplo en la
mutación está de chrys de la señora
aliria la paciente Tenía muchos menos
niveles de tau a nivel general en su
cerebro mientras que en el caso del
paciente J al que hemos hablado hoy más
específicamente había menos tau solo en
lugares específicos del cerebro sabemos
que ambos tenían mucho Beta amiloide
acumulado durante décadas y también
sabemos han identificado Cuáles son
estas dos mutaciones diferentes pero con
el mismo resultado retrasar bloquear el
alzheimer durante décadas si se
investigan mejor Cuáles son los
mecanismos que hacen que estas
mutaciones genéticas bloqueen la
aparición del Alzheimer durante tanto
tiempo se puede entender mejor Cómo
funciona la enfermedad es una
información muy valiosa en una
enfermedad tan Misteriosa no y
terminamos muy brevemente con una cita
que daba el principal investigador de
Estos tipos de estudios Francisco lopera
de la Universidad de Antioquia que dice
eso que la enfermedad y la cura habitan
juntas en la naturaleza en este caso en
este pequeño pueblo de yarumal que solo
hay que leer la naturaleza e imitarla si
lo logramos podemos retrasar la
aparición del Alzheimer durante 20 o 30
años Bueno un caso bastante curioso y
también muy prometedor mar Muchas
gracias por esta noticia Gracias Andrés
nos vemos mañana en otra nueva jornada